[Musique]
un jour triste plus vieux des arbres
sans faille une journée sans soleil télé
ce préambule
mais notre cinéaste qui est un homme
heureux et qui a gardé toutes ses
illusions et rêve d'enfant au lendemain
de noël a voulu nous faire partager sa
joie et pour ce faire nous a proposé une
visite au jardin d'acclimatation
c'est le lieu de prédilection de tous
les enfants tout y est prévu pour leurs
amusements et leur détente
grands et petits peuvent suivant leur
âge se divertir grâce à toutes les
installations mises à leur disposition
manèges avions on peut même apprendre à
ne pas avoir le mal de mer des boutiques
où l'on peut acheter des ballons des
parapluies et des chapeaux en papier
[Musique]
à
la pêche a ses adeptes c'est pourquoi on
tente sa chance avec un peu d'adressé de
patience on peut retirer de cette pêche
miraculeuse un petit canard aux poissons
le jardin d'acclimatation à 160 6 ans
sous le second empire c'était un lieu de
promenade fort prisé puisque sous
l'impulsion du baron haussmann et furent
tracées des allées sous bois aménager
des lacs artificiels et des cascades
napoléon iii s'y intéressa
personnellement aujourd'hui c'est le
domaine des enfants tout est prévu pour
qu'à chaque tournant derrière chaque
arbuste au bout de chaque année il
découvre avec ravissement et attractions
nouvelles et toujours irrésistible la
rivière enchantée le stand de tir à
l'arc que le golf miniature le palais
des automates le toboggan les
balançoires le tourniquet et beaucoup
d'autres attractions
mais au printemps c'est pourquoi nous
reviendrons par le petit train vous
découvrirez les variétés rares de fleurs
merveilleusement entretenue qui
s'épanouissent de toutes parts dans les
parterres et au long des années
[Musique]
ce n'est pas une recette culinaire mais
une invitation à la gourmandise
[Musique]
gourmands aussi cet ours qui quémandent
une douceur et vous remercie avec grâce
[Musique]
l'une embouteillages à craindre cette
piste ressemble à un anneau de vitesse
il suffit de savoir conduit d'être
prudent de doubler à gauche
[Musique]
l'illusion est complet qu'on peut rêver
vitesse et performance champion du
volant on l'est pendant quelques tours
de piste sous le regard admiratif des
futurs conducteurs
[Musique]
en
on
lieu écarquillés et brillant de plaisir
le rire ou le sérieux l'enfant est
émerveillé voici guignols et ses
pirouettes
il n'y a jamais relâche au jardin
d'acclimatation le merveilleux est
présent tous les jours
c'est pourquoi à la fin de cette visite
il m'a semblé apercevoir du ciel le
rayon seul
[Musique]